According to the Financial Times,
these are the best online NBA programs in 2023.
And graduate salaries three years post graduation.
Kicking things off at No.
10 is Polytechnical de Milano School of management
with the current salary of $165,000
and an impressive 35% salary increase.
Moving on to No. 9,
we have the university of Liverpool Management School
hosting a current salary of AHUNDRED61K
and a seller 32% salary increase.
In the eighth spot is Durham University Business School,
showing off a current salary of 157 K
and an 18% salary increase.
Next up at No. 7,
we got the university of Florida Warrington
rocking a current salary of 136 K
and a solid 25% salary increase.
Now at the sixth position
is a university of North Carolina
Keenan Flagger
with a current salary of 188,000
and a fantastic 29% salary increase.